welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 14. we
pick up where we left off at the
apartment building where the now crazy
carlson is searching for the stolen
commonwealth weapons on a secret mission
for lance hornsby maggie and the hilltop
crew are sneaking around pretty soon
they find the residents here including
negan they're pretty surprised to see
him but it's like where else was he
gonna end up there aren't that many
communities around they all go to the
secret room where the rest of the
residents are hiding and negan's like
what's up guys this is annie we're kind
of a thing oh that's cute but actually
it's kind of serious it's only been a
few months but they're already
apocalypse married and soon we find out
she's pregnant what negan my man moves
quick i did not see this one coming
speaking of kids maggie son herschel
stowed away in the truck and tagged
along on this mission now the
commonwealth has him so it's up to uncle
negan to bust down there and save him
like hey mags i guess i'll babysit for a
while this is obviously super awkward
because negan is the guy who killed his
father and hershel is a smart kid pretty
soon he figures that out and pulls a gun
on negan so these two have a chat and
negan still doesn't say the magic words
i'm sorry but he comes pretty close this
time admits that killing glenn was a
really bad thing and there's nothing he
could do to make it up and maybe even i
deserve to die but kid now is not the
time if you fire that gun the
commonwealth will find us so hershel
agrees to put this on hold meanwhile
back at the commonwealth daryl and
rosita reporting for duty as cops the
annoying [ __ ] douchebag sebastian
milton is trying to impress a girl it's
like hey bro daryl tell her how cool i
was when i killed zombies daryl
generally wants to be on this kid's good
side but hilariously his endorsement
doesn't come across as genuine in fact
he and rosita are called away from their
normal rounds to go on a secret mission
for sebastian milton he wants them to
get inside this mansion that's
surrounded by a horde of zombies why
what's so important inside turns out his
mom canceled his allowance and this is
his old friend's house whose dad kept a
bunch of cash in his safe daryl's like
absolutely the hell not but sebastian's
like hey what about your kids daryl
grabs this punk by the neck like you
threaten our kids i'll gut ya but he's
like oh i'm not threatening your kids
i'm just saying if you get that cash you
get a cut buy them a better life so
daryl and rosita cover their nice white
uniforms with zombie guts to walk on
inside but when they get to the safe
room turns out there's somebody else
already trapped in there yeah it turns
out they're not the first people
sebastian sent on this mission but this
woman wasn't a stormtrooper she's just a
random desperate citizen who was deep in
debt and sebastian sent on this suicide
mission because no one would miss her
and she's just one of a bunch he sent
like 40 other people to their deaths to
get this cash so yeah this crosses a
line from inappropriate use of
commonwealth resources to straight up
killing people for now though daryl's
got to turn the power on and he's
attacked by walkers and i bet it would
be an epic action sequence if it weren't
so dark i couldn't see any of it but now
the lights are on they get to the safe
find the cash but the alarm goes off and
all the zombies come in they're trapped
in there but now there's gunfire and
who's coming to save them it's mercer
and carol yeah daryl and carol were
supposed to have a classic daryl carroll
lunch today and he didn't show up she
went to mercer and tracked him down here
they explained to him what's going on
and mercer is not happy they cover
themselves with guts again to sneak on
out of there but this random woman isn't
well trained oh she gets eaten and they
all gotta fight their way out outside
mercer is like hey troopers what the
hell are you doing and they're like we
don't answer to you we answer to
sebastian and mercer puts down that
disobedience real quick shoots him both
in the head like i don't approve of this
but he's not gonna openly go against
sebastian so when they get back they
give him the cash and he's like hey good
job guys here's your cut don't spend it
all in one place but now daryl rosita
and to some extent mercer are not happy
with the commonwealth leadership carol
goes to her new best friend lance
hornsby and explains what sebastian's
been up to but of course he already knew
she's like i don't think you understand
he sent like 40 random civilians to
their deaths and he's like yeah the
drugs of society that was their own
fault okay so carol puts on her happy
face like yeah man you're right but when
she turns around she puts on the i might
have to kill that guy face lance hornsby
though is no fool he also puts on i
might have to have carol killed face now
back at the apartment complex crazy
carlson almost finds their secret room
but they've made a plan aaron and
gabriel lure him up to the roof where
it's time for elijah to put on his mask
and bust out the epic ninja skills
apparently they ambushed the rest of the
commonwealth troopers so now they've
retaken the building and have carlson at
their mercy and aaron shows no mercy
blam blam blam shoots him off the roof
he lands next to the pile of people he
just threw off the roof who have now
turned into zombies and carlson's
injured but still alive so he gets a
really gruesome death halloween
so the day is saved for now maggie's
like i knew the commonwealth was bad
news you guys want to come back to
hilltop but erin and gabriel aren't
ready to be fugitives yet they're like
we gotta go back try to figure out what
happened and maybe expose it but wait a
sec there's one more big mystery because
this group actually didn't steal the
guns and if it wasn't them who was it
that single-handedly ambushed the
commonwealth caravan
it is leah the last surviving reaper
what is she gonna do with the butt load
of guns find out next time on the
walking dead
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and news
[Music]